Hello folks,
I am back.
I'm going to add a few more tags in
here. We're going to get ourselves
pretty much a full profile
of this thing
and uh we're going to figure out where
we're leaking all the perf and hopefully
start optimizing some stuff. That is the
plan.
Now, I think we can also start deleting
some just other crap that we don't need.
All right. So,
anything under this?
We're still ignoring the
Yeah, we're still going to ignore the
environment in these profiles for now.
Um,
let's just do
this will be train misk.
Oh, puff advantage.
We can do puff advantage.
Hey, off market, welcome. Congrats on
your internship.
Didn't you say you were still
Were you not the guy that was in high
school?
high school's weird in Europe. Well,
grabs then, man. Work hard.
Try not to bungle too much social stuff,
though it's expected at your age. I
definitely did.
um try to produce something of real
value to them.
I'm surprised that Palunteer takes
foreign um interns
defense company. No,
but good good on you.
For some reason, defense gets a bad rap
among a lot of CS people,
and I honestly think it's just because
it's a bunch of wimps.
Defense tech is not exactly a bad thing.
It's actually quite a good
67.
Well, here's the thing I'll tell you
about socials, right? I never had them
growing up. They're awful. They are just
so terrible. But at the same time, look
at this.
I have built in the last couple of years
by posting mostly technical content.
This is probably the largest pure
reinforcement learning following out
there. Um, this has gotten me like quite
a substantial amount of real business
via inquiries from interested companies
about our professional stuff. It has
replaced traditional advertising. It's
meant that I haven't had to hire a
salesperson and it's gotten me a lot of
contacts as well. Um, so like X in
general,
the less you use it, like the less you
compulsively scroll it, the better, but
it is genuinely just indispensable at
this point. It's the best thing to have
happened to startups.
And this number is something that you
take with you
like this audience across many different
things that you can do. and it genuinely
just gives you a leg up on getting the
word out there about any new cool stuff
that you're doing.
This is very very valuable. Like
it the thing is the number is not
comparable to if like you're a fitness
influencer or something. Okay, that's
one thing. But if you have a large
following in a very specific technical
area like
I'd suggest articles. A lot of my
follows came from articles. Like if you
write a good article on a topic, you
know, some of these
475k views and then I can like I
especially like that I can point people
to these, right? I can like send people
over to these
And sometimes the thing is like actually
cool people on X, the coolest thing I
think that has ever happened was uh
Carmarmac retweeting this article saying
that it's good advice. That's basically
the proudest thing that I have
cuz like you know that's somebody I just
genuinely have so much respect Four.
Read it yesterday.
Yeah, I would highly suggest that you
keep coming back to that post every so
often because it's one thing to read it
and it's one thing to like fully
understand it. Um,
like a lot of the lines in that post are
not just me casually telling you
something. It's like if I I can't
possibly shout it any louder, right?
It's like this one thing, if you do this
wrong, you will waste 2,000 hours of
your life on something completely
worthless and it will make you
miserable.
Yeah, sure.
I mean, you realize most of the reason I
stream is so I can chat with people who
are interested in getting into this
stuff and who are using my things and
like have questions and hey, we get a
lot of new people as well. We've had um
I've had a couple high school students
start building stuff around Puffer as
well.
It's not too early to start on this
stuff. Some of the math is going to be a
little early, but like learning some
low-level dev gem in some simple
environments, you can totally do that.
worth going to China for university.
What?
Since when has anybody said that, man?
Who on earth told you that? Like, no.
Where on earth did you get that?
Holy hell.
That's got to be one of the nuttiest
questions I've gotten.
My criticism of the US education does
not imply that I think that other places
have better
I got Oxford here. Why would you go Why
would you say China instead of like
America, dude?
We've got a lot of problems, but I still
think it's the best country on earth.
Like, there's a lot of stuff you can
like, there's so much opportunity in the
US.
Um,
it's the easiest place in the world to
start and build companies.
Like you can be a technical person, like
a very good technical person that is
barely passable business-wise and you
can build something awesome.
Yeah, EU in general is UK and EU in
general are absolutely terrible for
that.
That's not politics. That's just law.
That's like objective business law.
I started Puffer two years ago and we
have a profitable business.
Good growth.
Awesome. Awesome science progress.
And I also have no idea what's wrong
with the uh UK compensation, but nobody
makes any money over there. It's like
they just do not value town whatsoever.
It's nuts.
food scholarship if you need a
scholarship and are like and need to
take like a not top well I guess it
depends who I'm talking to if you're
good enough to get into a top school in
the US um obviously do that if you need
a scholarship and can get somewhere
that'll give you one. Like the top ones
usually give need-based aid anyways. But
if you can do that, like getting to the
US is very useful, very very useful.
It's just that like honestly I know a
lot of people that didn't go to top
universities. It's just the thing is the
university is going to help you a lot
less, right? So more of what the what is
just done for you is going to be on you
to go and get,
you know, like coming from a Stanford
degree or an MIT degree, you're
basically at least guaranteed an
interview anywhere you want and like a
fasttrack one at a lot of places. You
don't just get your resume ignored
forever.
um
it's way easier to fund raise
just because the thing is the like they
get so much volume that the credentials
check is just the easiest way for them
to filter. So some of that stuff is
harder but just being in the US in
general at least there is opportunity
here even if it is harder and there just
ain't
in the EU for the most part.
undergrad from Stanford, PhD. How are
you? That's a way to address me. I'm
Joseph. Hello. Yeah, I've seen you in
chat.
Aren't the fees crazy?
You mean the
uh the tuition fees for undergrad? Yes.
The top schools have So the top schools
have a lot of need-based aid though.
It's not true for the like the worst
schools,
but the top schools have they don't just
give you loans, they give you financial
aid, right? So you don't end up with a
whole bunch of debt.
it's definitely worth looking into at
the least again if you're of the caliber
that you can get in to the top places
that is right dramatically diminishing
returns slower but then depending on
other prospects I mean Oxford is also
great like if you can just go to Oxford
that's also Great.
I mean, you can also do like undergrad
there and then come here for grad school
or come here for like, you know, to join
a startup or whatever else.
I do think that generally prospects if
you get to the US at some point are way
better.
It's also just a pretty great country.
It's a big country. Like,
you can kind of pick wherever you want
to be. There's there's kind of an area
that's like that. I'm in Florida right
now. Um, it's super chill. I've got a
good gym here, a bunch of good food, but
other than that, I got peace and quiet,
and I still have the business laws,
right? So, I can like build my company
from right here.
Munich is the best in Europe.
Haven't been there. No idea. I've been
to a bunch of places in Europe, though.
I'm not just totally speaking out of my
ass.
Been around, you know, Paris, London,
full Mediterranean, uh, coast,
um,
few other countries.
SF overhyped.
Yeah, SF is a mess. Um,
so basically you go to SF if you want to
join the rat race and win it.
My favorite saying is that the winner of
a rat race is a rat. So I'm not in that
stuff and I still build real like I
still be build real stuff, you know.
Family's doing well.
So
hey that guy, welcome.
What we got here?
We got a profile. Right. So we have 5.3
2.4 7.7
8.7
9.
So this is 95% plus of the 10-second
profile. So I pretty much caught
everything.
You assume people just want to work for
companies though. If you want to start
companies, US
Gain Street. Why Gain Street? Oh, yeah.
You like font stuff, right?
I work with like a a few pool finance
startups.
I think I've developed a pretty negative
opinion of big like big finance over the
years just from the type of people I've
met.
10% on output.
Really?
What are you doing?
This is text string
green misk
What is this roll out copy output
taking? Oh no, that's expected, right?
Um, not exactly. This is I'm just doing
a hard synchronize.
So it's not actually grouping by graphs.
I just like came up with some labels. So
this is adding the profile is adding
overhead via the syncs here.
I wonder actually how fast this is.
Use the RL.
Well, how am I supposed to do that?
Even if I use the RL on League of
Legends
visa to work in the US is not easy.
Um
it is if you're good
and not it's if you're good and you
don't happen to be on the list of like
countries where it's really difficult to
get a visa from. Right.
most of Europe. Not that hard.
Okay, so we're taking like some sort of
a per hit, 10% on profile, but that
should still be pretty accurate. Let me
see what we got here.
Okay, so these are
unblocking.
Uh let me see. Copy.
No. Is this all like Mr. Hill?
How do I get good start contributing to
Puffer? I mean, that is a way to learn
stuff, right? If you're interested in
what I work on, um,
you can follow my general programming
guide, which is just do a bunch of
projects and it gives you some general
advice. If you're interested in RL
specifically, we have a bunch of stuff
to work on that will involve low-level
dev and some AI. I'm not going to say
that doing stuff on my project is the
only way to get good. It is a pretty
unique uh it's a pretty unique thing if
you're interested in this area
specifically though and it does teach
you some general skills.
I don't have any courses to sell you.
I did this.
Oh, hang on.
So it was 10.7% before one second worth
of time.
I won't have courses to sell. My content
is free.
I don't really have any in like I don't
really see the point of trying to
monetize users. I'd rather just keep all
my stuff free and charge companies.
did that um
That's weird, right?
That can't be right, right?
Hang on.
Can that be correct?
Something should not be that slow. But
is
why is the standard deviation so high?
No idea.
It's kind of cool though that we're
going to have this whole thing and we
just don't need Torch Compile anymore
cuz honestly Torch Compile is just so
bad.
Okay. So this is updating correctly.
Two wait this is 2.5%.
Oh this is graph state I suppose.
Then what is taking all the time on this
right?
Is it not the ops taking the time?
So weird.
Let me just double check.
Uh
can you link me that please? Because
that's actually a huge bottleneck that I
have right now. And the uh doing a
custom kernel for that is like awful.
Like that's actually That's probably the
last remaining thing that I have that I
just don't know what the hell to do
about.
Yes, RMS norm is like ludicrously slow.
It's actually a bottleneck in
uh both what we're doing and for a
couple companies using our stuff.
Oh, 1.3. Ah, dude, it's like way slow.
Do you really need RMS norm? Is there
not like another thing you could just
do? Why the hell do we need these stupid
norm layers anyways?
Okay, so this is odd to me that it's
basically the same
latency
with or without the obs copy
DSLs
kernels.
Um, Mojo's a company's language. I doubt
that
one of the DSLs. I mean, people use
Triton at the moment. I really don't
enjoy Triton.
Man, the thing is Cuda, it's like Nvidia
Harbor only,
but
me
read the paper. Well, obviously I read
the paper like many years ago. Yeah,
keep within stable bounds or whatever,
but can we do that thing without having
an incredibly slow, stupid operation
that takes like a 2 million step per
second bite out of our performance to do
nothing?
Also, why is there not an instruction to
do a copy and cast at the same time?
[clears throat]
Is that dumb?
That might be dumb. I don't know.
Okay, so this is still
Huh.
Well, I honestly I don't believe that
it's not the int the compute intensity
of the norm op that is doing anything,
man. It's literally I guarantee you it's
just some researchers tried out some
norms. They saw that it made uh the
network do better without regard to
flops, not understanding what a kernel
even is and then everybody started using
it. Like I doubt that it's it's not like
really there's been a lot of work on how
do we get these norms that are actually
able to be implemented in a way that is
efficient.
Like literally the multiple teams that
we're working on, there's one specific
project that they didn't even realized
that their norms were slow for months.
People just don't think about this
stuff,
you know? I want to try
I kind of want to try something. I'm
trying to think how I do it.
Uh, the backward pass for RMS norm is
just awful.
If you work it out, it's awful.
Wonder if it's this action buffer. This
is N64. I wonder if there's just some
weird thing with N64.
Well, but like that guy, you get cross
terms in the um you get cross terms in
the gradient.
So, it's like pretty easy to do the
forward. There's one annoying sync
point, but then it's pretty easy to do
the forward. But the backward is just
faking terrible
for RMSORM. I don't remember if I did,
but like I didn't mean it's awful
computing. Like I mean if you're going
to go try to do a custom form a custom
kernel to do it faster like even writing
out those ops is horrible.
See it's like a flat profile.
I took a little bite out of it.
I bet it's just all these dumb strided
copies, right?
Let's make sure it's not the cast real
quick.
I've been thinking of restructuring this
for a while.
It's kind of a subtle point, but um
so the way I have it now, you need to do
a strided copy
in order to uh set all these like when
you're moving stuff around here. Strided
copy is not ideal.
Does this need a kernel?
How does this work if it doesn't need a
kernel?
Oh, it's in TT.
Wait. Transformer tricks.
Wait.
it might be okay if we do this and then
linear. I think right now we're doing
norm and skip connect, but like we can
mess with the architecture to see what
works.
See if this runs or crashes. This might
just crash.
I'm trying to think if there's a way I
can run this that will just like
The cast are not slow.
It's got to just be these fried copies.
Um, I'm trying to think if there's a way
I can figure that out.
There's like
Select
one and H.
I wonder if I do zero. If I just do
this, maybe it breaks, maybe it doesn't,
right?
Like this is obviously wrong,
but if it'll just like do the memory
copy, I just need it to do the copy and
not crash for the speed test
cuz like I was thinking of basically
transposing our roll out buffer.
Um, which would cut down quite a lot on
this form of overhead.
Um,
I have a feeling this is a No, it's run.
Yeah. Okay. So, it crashed.
It didn't run.
I mean, I can write a quick test
probably right
here. Actually, this is I probably can
um
All right, LM lovers. We will use the LM
for once.
If it messes this up though, I like I
don't even know what to say.
if I use if I use Sonnet I think people
will complain even less for whatever
reason. Do people think Sonnet is better
than Grock 41?
I don't know. When I tried them, they
both just sucked.
But whatever. We'll try this.
This actually probably should work. I'll
actually be surprised. This is so
simple.
Wait, can I was it t set column major
would be it, right?
Oh, we could do that.
That actually makes sense, doesn't it?
Okay.
Did it actually run it? No, it didn't
actually run it.
Fast any good?
I'm using sonnet because at the moment
because people complain when I use grot
just to show whether it's any better. I
doubt it is. That would be very
surprising to me if this profile is the
case. I bet it's cached.
actually I can just mess with it. All
right.
Well, at the very least, the test that
Sonic gave me was complete [ __ ]
because it was just spending half the
time in a do item call. So,
lo and behold, I give it something
incredibly simple and it's still totally
stupid.
I don't know if it changes the
qualitative result, but the execution
was total [ __ ]
So, good job.
Got CUDA on here. Yeah, some device
CUDA.
Uh,
narrow
zero
block size.
Can this possibly be optimized?
Like
But why
is this profile giving us the exact same
speed?
Yeah, I remember that. But I'm trying to
figure out Yo, that guy, wouldn't you
expect um row major copy to be way
faster than column major copy?
still warp.
I'd be surprised.
Oh, wait. It's warming up.
profile profile.
I bet it's caching [ __ ]
No
10x size.
Well, that's not the actual size I'm
using, right?
But I like fair point. You would think
that this fits in memory.
Now it says column major is faster which
doesn't make any bloody sense
right.
Yeah. I don't know how column major is
faster than all this. Let me just double
check.
It's going to be contiguous, dude. These
are new tensors. These are brand new
tensors.
They're allocated contiguous.
Oh, wait. Is this thing
No, it's fine.
almost dim 1 mil. Why would I do that?
If it doesn't make a difference on
things this small, this is going to like
be I don't know how much memory is this.
And
There we go.
See, column major is still faster in
this.
I mean, it should just be freaking
memory, right? Like 2D 1D, it's all just
memory.
I was looking for like a 10% perf win
cuz I have some copies in the C++ that
should nowhere near be
as slow as they are.
B decides to be intelligent. I don't
know.
Well, hang on. It's queuing all of them,
right?
What if you have to sync?
There we go.
column major very slightly faster
in watch iteration.
Select and narrow don't copy though,
dude. So select and narrow. This is the
same as doing fancy indexing like this
is the same as doing uh of like colon
uh one. Was it a colon one?
No, colon h.
Uh, and then this one is the same as
doing like h colon. And then narrow is
like the same as doing from like
what is this? from this like this. Colon
this.
Yeah, it should be a way bigger
difference, right? Okay,
let's just take this nonb blocking stuff
out real quick
cuz I'm like I'm worried. queuing stuff
and not synchronizing somehow.
But I would expect a huge difference,
wouldn't you? Like,
unless we're just profiling overhead.
We could totally just be profiling
overhead.
I mean, there is a speed up, but it's
like negligible.
Oh, unless this narrow.
What if I just don't do this narrow off?
or 1% difference.
H
could you not make it's a new call
not just make one obs block
wait I think the narrow
select our narrow
what do you mean
make one ops block
the point of this is that the point of
this is to test um row major versus
column major your copy speed.
It's probably flattening and copying
over. Yeah, but it should be
non-ontiguous target memory address,
right? That guy. That should be
substantially slower. No, just try to
copy
column then row.
Yeah, I did that. Oops, not that one.
Other way doesn't make a difference.
See, same thing.
One's still faster here.
But it's not a big diff.
Market puffer game dev. I do say that
and it is gamedev. Like you literally
just do chill low-level gamedev and then
you also train AI on it at 10,000 times
real speed.
Okay. Well, I guess the alternative is
to ask why the hell is this slow then?
If this should be like native copy
speed, right?
I mean, we can comment these clamps.
Let's just do these ones, right?
See if these buffers are any good.
dispatch and view overhead
mostly business. So that is totally
possible. Um,
the better thing would be to set it up,
I suppose, in C++,
but you're still going to have the
dispatch overhead, right?
Let me run one more thing and then I'll
go back to it. Hang on.
I forget it's a CUDA operation. You're
right.
So, I could do it on CPU and that would
give me some timings,
but um
it is literally just going to be the
Well, no, wait. The dispatch should be
milliseconds.
How long we should look how long this
copy is expected to take
6.2% is still. So, it's like a very
linear flat profile on this thing.
Well, now they're both super slow, but
they're the same speed.
Yeah. So these are like same.
Am I totally wrong to think that? Um,
I thought it was way faster to do
like a ro major copy,
but from this profile it looks to be the
same.
profile may reveal more.
Well, like
is there a way I can test it here?
You know, I bet there is a way I can
test it here real quick.
single large copy. But that's not the
case I'm profiling for, Nicholas.
Okay. So, the way that we test this, I
believe,
um, so we're going to do this.
[snorts]
These ones,
if we make them here
in memory, true.
Uh, why the hell would that matter? It's
device device transfer.
just see if we get a very different
profile out of Yes.
Is that very different?
5.7.
So, it really seems like there's not um
a huge amount to gain.
But then why
wait this is 27 microsconds,
isn't it?
Oh,
wait. Nanc
is 27 microsconds.
How does that make sense? That's tiny.
Hey, Jess.
Yeah, I This was my bad. I didn't read
the unit. This is tiny tiny. So then how
Okay, then. Oh, wait. This is super
fast.
Huh?
Wait, that's kind of crazy, isn't it?
How is it?
Whoa. Our forward pass is really fast
then, isn't it?
Isn't that what's happening? Is just our
forward pass is like stupid fast.
I was thinking like oh our copy is slow
but actually I think it's just that
everything else is really fast light.
18,000 instances.
It's about right, isn't it? For 76
million steps.
Any merit to buy these AI subscriptions?
missing out.
Um,
I mean, go use one of the free ones for
a bit and see how you like it,
right?
Like, if you use it and you like it,
like a $20 a month sub is a perfectly
fine thing to get. I don't think that
you would need a $200 a month sub.
I'm kind of just mentally trying to
reprocess
This
can you graph this?
Actually, that's another that's another
LLM question.
buffer copy path is efficient. Not
necessarily.
Wait,
what?
This shows the buffer copy path itself,
but not necessarily necessarily really
much about the full forward pass. Wait,
Nicholas, this is saying
look
this is that my entire model forward
pass is 130 microsconds,
right? So all this is saying is my model
is really fast. It's not that the copies
are super slow. This is only 53
microsconds.
It's just that this is so well optimized
that by comparison, yeah, this is
actually substantial overhead,
right?
see. It's trying to graph the entire
loop.
Are you [ __ ] me, dude?
Fine. I'm just going to show you that
this is like
it's the same [ __ ]
Okay, this is the exact same output the
other model gave me, dude.
Okay, I don't have a sub yet. I said I
was going to do this on stream next week
or I guess now this week, but like I
just want to understand what is going
through your head that you think that
like the more intelligent model fixes
this. Like
is this problem a black box to you?
because like I don't know that there is
a reasonable other solution to the
problem as phrase that I have not
thought of.
Like I think I'm going to have to
reframe or something.
Why is he still employed by anthropic
then?
You think that the big companies like
employ all good people?
No,
that's not how it works.
Tired as hell. I went to the gym for a
good couple hours. Ran 8 minute pace 5K.
Did some heavy bench.
Took a couple plates. Did some super
light squats because I haven't done that
in a year. I'm getting back into it. Few
other things.
You can't. That's the thing, Jess, is
you can't because it's computebound.
This is why RL is so because I don't I'm
not compute bound. It's like it's just
skill bound basically and edgebound.
small models for specific tasks. Hey,
what what do you know? That's what RL
does. They're not for text tasks, right?
They're mostly for fiddly, unintuitive
optimization problems, which is a lot of
different areas.
That is what I'm working on.
Um,
okay. So, before I go ahead and do this,
like
I could graph
I could make 128 graphs here, right?
Like people see this,
you know, I could just graph this off
for each h
Uhoh.
10 is
I'm confused. amount time to instantiate
a graph dominates the run time for
adopting the graph.
Ah yes this is fine first CP if you
repeat
Can somebody explain this to me?
The whole [ __ ] point of this right is
like it's not supposed to scale like
this, isn't it?
I think I'm reading it wrong because the
graphs imply different right launch.
Yeah. So,
device runtime.
Oh, wait. Repeat launch
prompt and get worked on just the [ __ ]
Yeah, that sucked.
Did they just not put this in here?
So wait, they're saying on 126
CPU overhead of repeat launches of
straight line graphs with large straight
line topology,
right?
Straight line graphs. Every node is a
single dependent node except for the
last node.
Launching a graph that has already been
uploaded to the device.
I got 20 minutes. Do you guys think I
can trace um 128 graphs in um I mean we
can try it right?
Yeah, it's not that hard I think. Right.
Um
Plus 10% could be
almost plus 10%.
one batch.
Uh yeah, it's 128 graphs in a batch and
you get to reuse them. So
yeah. So, I have to do it is super
annoying. We'll do it quick and then
I'll come fix it later.
But, uh, I just want to see if this
fixes like I want to see if things are
sane in CUDA graph land. I
Nope. Cold showers and cold water in
general is
great way to reduce muscle growth
and
make yourself uncomfortable for no
reason when if you're going to be
uncomfortable like be more uncomfortable
in training.
I'd rather train hard and then like take
a nice warm shower. Thank you very much.
Yeah, it turns out stoicism type stuff
just doesn't work because um you know
you can train hard and you can have a
lot of discipline, but if that's all you
do, you just have depression because
there's just nothing to look forward to.
So yeah,
labs are people who actually know linear
algebra.
Uh knowing linear algebra is not really
the
it's not exactly the uh bottleneck.
Like pretty much everybody knows linear
algebra. It's mostly that nobody can
write decent code.
No shower pro isn't
a sigma male bull.
I ran uh 8 minute pace 5k at the gym
today.
Rep 225 bench. Squat was terrible. Like
210 or I don't know six or eight. Um but
I have not squatted in literally a year.
So,
Put the effort into training. Don't put
the effort into torturing yourself for
literally no reason. There are not even
substantial recovery benefits to that.
Nope, not at all. Bisect I do
occasionally use.
Cherry pick. I never use it. Always just
messes crap up.
sauna. I don't enjoy sauna. I have a hot
tub. Well, at least I do in California.
I will have one at the warehouse soon.
Hot tub is good. Honestly, the best
thing for recovery, like you can look it
up. It's just being able to actually
relax. So whatever you do that you
actually enjoy and just relaxes you is
pretty much it.
And get sleeping food obviously.
What do we think guys? Is this
completely stupid?
How's this stuff all get past?
Oh, it does get all passed in.
Like, do you have a good diet? Do you
eat well? I guess meds can, you know,
screw up.
That's not just like a diet and eat well
thing.
kind of hacking this thing to pieces,
but I kind of want to try this. And I
got to run for dinner. Actually, I got
to go for dinner in 5 minutes. Shoot.
Um, let me see if I can get this to run.
Work, gym, run. Uh, I mean, games are
kind of a vice for me, I suppose, for
when I'm really tired.
I did my thesis on MMOs. You think I'd
played a fair bit of them if I wrote my
thesis on AI and MMOs.
Like, yeah,
right.
Other than that, I listen to audiobooks
mostly while I'm working out and doing
other stuff. That's pretty much it. I
try not to like add a ton of other
things into my life. You know, this is
really my main focus.
Oh, we don't need this. Good thing I
bought this for
this gym. Yeah, but I got to go for
dinner in a few. I was just doing a
couple quick things.
I think we do actually have um
like ignore the fact that it's a total
mess for now.
I can leave that as actually
RL courses and textbooks.
Uh I'm not actually aware of any good
ones is the problem.
Uh check my RL guide from a list of
resources. It's on X.
Don't you have a girl? Yeah. You asked
for hobbies though. That's not a hobby.
How have I not asked you this yet? What
do you think about Rich Sutton?
Uh Rich Sutton is cool. Like obviously
you have to give the guy a huge amount
of respect for his contributions to the
foundation of Borl.
Godfather of the field. Um, I listen I
didn't listen to his Door Crash one
though. Like I listened to him give an
actual technical talk at RLC.
So I think that's going to be way more
representative. Um, the current stuff
he's working on is kind of high level
and abstracted.
Uh, at least like his public stuff. I
don't know what he's doing with Keen
though. They have produced some of the
better RL stuff out there. It's just in
a very different direction from what I'm
currently interested in. Does everyone
eat meat for breakfast? Yeah, protein
good for you. Steak and egg, man.
And let me just get this last trumpet
thing done and uh we should be good.
Yeah. So, we want to have
Uh, auto ops prefer
get the policy
back. Do you need back?
I didn't do that. No, you don't need
back at all.
Actually, wait. You don't even need the
policy.
We're good, right?
What about buff state?
What do you do
that
lake?
I really don't want like a lot of other
things in my life.
I mean like what I'm working on is
incredibly meaningful to me.
You know like this is
the field is a different field because
of this library than it was two years
ago by a huge margin. You know we have
RL in applications where it would have
never been before. We have a clear path
board as well.
What is this chat? I have no idea, man.
I'm just casually answering [ __ ] while I
try to trace 128 cudigraphs. So, I think
I got to go.
Yeah. So, I'm going to finish this
later. Um, the plan is just that uh that
guy. The plan is we're just going to
trace there only 128 graphs. So, I don't
know if there's weird caching or stuff,
if there's a max number, but I think I
just trace all 128 graphs. It'll take
like, you know, a tiny fraction of a
second to do that at startup. And then I
think that that should crush this 57 ms
down to like five or 10. So, we should
get plus probably like plus 5 to 700,000
steps per second train out of that. And
then there a few little chunks of
overhead here. And then there's colonel
op, but that should mostly get us to 10
mil.
Oh, cool. All right, for everyone
watching, thanks for tuning in. Uh, I
will be live. Should be streaming all
day tomorrow, I think, depending. Still
subject to schedule. Oops, not that.
Uh, if you're interested in my stuff,
puffer.ai.
Please star the puffer. Feed the puffer
star on GitHub. It actually really helps
me a lot. It's free. Other than that,
join Discord if you want to get
involved. Follow me on extra more RL
content, including articles.